Happy Thanksgiving everyone I just
wanted to make a really quick video to
say especially today I mean I know I say
it a lot in almost every video I do but
I just wanted to reiterate just how
grateful I am for what you guys have
done to change my life I mean I wouldn't
even be here doing this right now if it
wasn't for you I wouldn't be able to
make videos doing something that I
really enjoy doing for a living if it
wasn't for you guys and I'm just
eternally grateful for that fact and
what you guys have done it people say
that I do a lot of good for you guys is
live but in reality I would be nothing
without you and I never want to forget
that and I never want to make or I want
to make sure that you guys never think
that I'm not grateful because I am and I
always will be today I'm gonna be
spending some time with my family I'm
gonna be doing the Thanksgiving dinners
and whatnot I hope you guys have a great
holiday I mean if you do then the Black
Friday stuff hey best of luck to you I
don't do that myself mostly because I
don't want to stick around the crowds
and I it's like the rush of consumerism
I don't know that's a whole different
subject but I kind of tend to stay away
from that but just I hope you have a
great holiday no matter what if you're
spending it with family if you're
spending with friends or even if you're
spending it alone I hope you have a
great time and just from me to you I
hope you have a great day and just thank
you again for everything that you've
done for me
so that's it thank you all so much and
I'll see you in the next video bye